this was the moment when the speaker of
israel's parliament the knesset
announced that last-ditch efforts to
pass the budget had failed
there was no way forward for the fragile
ruling alliance
unfortunately we were unable to find
enough common ground to prevent another
round of elections
and enable the 23rd kenneset and its
members to exercise the mandate given to
us
we are all going to face a difficult
election campaign and i call on each and
every one of us
and on each and every israeli citizen to
refrain from exacerbating tensions
prime minister benjamin netanyahu's
popularity has sank
over the government's handling of the
coronavirus pandemic
he's also facing a corruption case which
fueled divisions with netanyahu's
coalition partner
as well as within his own life party a
faction recently broke away
but if it's an inconvenient time for the
governing coalition to collapse
netanyahu didn't show it
we are against elections it's a wrong
decision by the blue and white party
but if an election is forced upon us i
promise you that we will win
analysts say prime minister netanyahu
may be overconfident
as the political landscape has changed
in the past three years
he's certainly very weak much weaker
than he has been politically for a long
time
uh not only because he faces this uh
looming corruption trial
but also because israelis really widely
believe he's mishandled
the pandemic uh they're suffering
economically as a result of that
and of course uh donald trump will no
longer be in the white house
uh by that time so so some of the
factors that have allowed him to
prevail in the past aren't there israeli
politicians will be entering the new
year in campaign mode
for the elections in march although
polls suggest that lahood
could still emerge as the largest party
it may need alliances to reach a 61-seat
majority
to former government barbara angopa al
jazeera